[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui bien des paramètres comme si c'est
melissa maulin dit pluie donc cette
semaine j'ai envie de vous sortir un peu
de la maison parce que le sujet que j'ai
envie d'approcher c'est celui du défi ou
skate 5 km
c'est un défi a été lancé par david gill
qui nous encourage à aller prendre vos
chaussures allait marcher dehors mais de
le faire d'une façon intelligente donc
ils nous envoient quotidiennement un
exercice pour commencer à faire une
marche trop lente pour pouvoir ensuite
vers courir 5 km sans s'arrêter
vous comprendrez que moi personnellement
j'ai des blessures aux chevilles je suis
je fais très attention pour pompes par
mal donc d'avoir une approche qui est
vraiment respectueux justement de nous
nos incapacités physiques du fait qu'on
a été aussi un petit peu sédentaires
pendant le temps des fêtes et pendant
l'hiver mais que ledit confinement fait
que l'extérieur est extrêmement agréable
on peut aller marcher qu'on peut aller
prendre l'air tout en respectant la
distanciation sociale puis les consignes
justement les couvre-feux et bien ça
nous permet de pouvoir faire une
activité physique sécuritaire mais le
vrai aspect qui m'a vraiment accroché
par rapport aux défis de jeu 4 5 km de
david c'est le fait que ça se fait en
communaux il ya un plaisir comme une opa
qui est en train de se créer autour du
défi donc il ya eu des milliers de gens
suivent presque 2000 les inscriptions
aux défis et une dizaine environ 10000
commence par poser dessous les postes
qui se faisait par les personnes qui
faisaient le défi qu'ils font encore
donc vous voyez il ya comme un
encouragement communautaire et je pense
que c'est cet aspect communautaire qui a
fait que j'ai voulu embarquer dans le
défi d'ailleurs j'ai vu une attache et
canapés façon début je dis un mot si je
veux le faire charlie jade et ça marche
donc je vous encourage et je vois de
plus en plus de communauté le fond des
défis soin de santé soit de nourriture
pour pouvoir encourager à rester en
forme et en santé
je répète le mot santé plusieurs
français qu'il faut pas oublier que dans
notre culture beaucoup je pense aussi
nous parce que l'on est particulièrement
le défi du skate chez les innu la
mobilité c'était là la culture la vie on
se déplaçait sur le territoire que ce
soit en raquettes en canot en luge pour
pouvoir aller chasser donc les innus ont
connu comme des grands marcheurs
cependant avec la sédentarisation forcée
les pensionnaires les jobs sédentaires
on a maintenant on perd beaucoup de
notre capacité à marcher à au quotidien
c'est à dire tous les jours des
kilomètres et des kilomètres son marché
on a plus ça maintenant et je pense
beaucoup à une histoire que mon chef
jean-charles piétacho mo partagés un été
c'était sur le procès de la chaise
il me racontait que c'était un aîné qui
avait déjà invité d'autres signaux à
venir qu'ils disent est il avait mis une
chaise au centre de la conversation pdc
comme s'il faisait le procès de la
chaise et qu'il disait laissez pas
rentrer les chaises dans vos maisons
vous allez perdre
la force de ce qui fait la nation et
nous c'est à dire la force dans vos
jambes la capacité de marcher de
déplacés donc en faisant le défi et
j'aime et pressent pour son brise quand
même un pli que la colonisation nous a
amenés on revient vers des manières de
s'encourager aussi de façon
communautaire et donc ça fait ressortir
les besoins des communautés ce qui était
un peu à l'avant scène justement de la
réussite par exemple des deux directs de
distanciation dans les communistes pour
ça qu'on n'a pas eu des cas tombe dans
les communautés en face au co vide est
là donc je suis encouragée à garder le
moral a marché a été en santé et on va
en voir de plus en plus pendant l'été je
pense que ça va peut-être permettre de
revenir vers des pratiques qui nous font
du bien que nous renforcent mutuellement
donc je vous encourage à aller voir avec
le mot clic ou chiquette ou auch 25 km
us hp a été
pour voir justement des efforts qui sont
faites par la communauté la fierté aussi
quand et l'encouragement et la
solidarité qui a dans la communauté
ils n'étaient pas prêts à participer
même si vous n'êtes pas des i nous parce
qu'on défend commencé avec un premier
pas et on crée d'enfants un sentiment de
communauté qui va peut-être extérieur
justin nations unies alors je souhaite
une belle semaine une bonne marche et
n'hésitez pas à partager cette vidéo